uh julio jones arrived at the tennessee
titans facility
yesterday
exciting times oh probably here
here's the thing though look at look at
this guy is
you know just a professional athlete if
i'm john robinson i'm not leaning in for
a hug with this guy i'm not standing
next to julio jones because it just
points out to everybody one of these
guys is in great shape and the other one
is not that was the first thing i
thought of when i saw that i'm not going
near julio jones with a camera around
that guy he is in great shape oh he is a
specimen of specimens i mean he really
is first off great luggage a lot i mean
that's when you know you're a real star
when they sign you or trade and then
they send the personal team jet for you
that's when you know you're like in the
upper stratosphere of players in the nfl
and john robinson's cool he's the kind
of guy he could check his ego he's like
i've been around these studs all my life
i'm not a stud they are who cares what i
look like he's all about football but
like mike julio i saw him on the field
in the 2009 national championship game
when they were playing texas right i was
on the field for pre-game at the out in
the rose ball and i can remember seeing
him out there and it was one of those
moments just like i've had you've heard
me with kalia's campbell where i just
looked at him and i went oh my gosh
that's julio jones that's a receiver
built like that
muscles popping out everywhere i mean he
is a specimen of specimens no doubt
meanwhile i have this image of pat
boland sending a piper cub to pick you
up
the tactical
yellow a yellow taxi here you go
yeah there's there was nothing sent for
me
now corey davis was a top 10 pick of the
tennessee titans they didn't pick up the
fifth year option i saw someone point
out and this was one of those like man i
wish i would have thought of it they
could have had corey davis on a fifth
year option i think it was mike sandow
of the athletic corey davis's fifth year
option actually would have been more
than what julio jones is making this
year
with his 15.3 million dollar contract
how much of an upgrade do we anticipate
julio jones to be over corey davis i i i
mean
i think significant because julio jones
is a guy that just is like we we've
talked about what he can do after the
catch you know what he can do before the
snap he's one of those guys oh it's one
on one i'm going to him and as we
mentioned yesterday he's also one of
those guys oh he's covered but it
doesn't really matter i can throw it up
to him and he'll still catch it that's
where
he's almost unstoppable in that manner
when it comes to one-on-one coverage
he's just a a a little bit of a
different beast than corey davis and
here's how i look at it too if corey
davis was julio jones
you pick up the fifth year hospital well
there you go you're not you're not in a
situation where you have to trade for
julio jones exactly you already have a
future julio jones a guy who was drafted
higher than julio jones when he came out
of western michigan i think it was so uh
yeah he would still be there and he
would probably be under his second
contract right now not his fifth year
option yeah exactly right corey davis a
good route runner you want him on your
football team he's a high end number two
but like we talked about yesterday
tennessee's going with
no we got
a high-end number one a high-end number
one and maybe the number one running
back in football too and then we got a
quarterback who's damn good and can
throw the ball down the field and is
aggressive and all that and that's where
i get really excited about that formula
again like we talked about yesterday
they're gonna put defenses in a real
bind you know it's rare to have a team
that can run the ball like that and have
two options on the outside that are
truly game changers and that's i think
the beauty of the trade off together
because yeah you can get away with one
guy on the outside and oh we're gonna
shade the safety over there to protect
our corner but we can bring down the
other safety and help out in the run
game a little bit and do that now you're
gonna have to think about think twice
with both of those guys and that's where
it's it's very interesting
all right so let's fill in the blank
receiving duos first topic the best
receiver duo in the nfl as of right now
is who chris it's i i i it's hard for me
to not say them i mean look like i'm
picking to pick aj brown and julio jones
right now aren't you or are you going to
go somewhere else
like you want to do for sake of the
exercise or do somebody else besides
them
i mean we've nev they've never been on
the field together yeah how about justin
jefferson and adam i mean they're right
up there with it no doubt about it i
mean that that's they're a part of the
next group them
dk dk and tyler lockett up there in
seattle i think they're in that
conversation even though it wasn't the
greatest year
last year i think mike evans and chris
godwin still got to be in that
conversation as well like they're just
they're difference makers so i look at
them as being in that category right
um obj and jarvis landry if obj could be
healthy have the potential to be that
but we haven't really seen that yet but
i think those are the ones right off the
bat that jump out to me that are at
least in the class of julio and ab
anybody else jump to your mind
i you know i'm pete has put together a
list of them i just there aren't two
that i just say wow bang pow those guys
are combined now you've got teams that
maybe have you know you're throwing a
tight end like the chiefs like i'm not
going to say tyree killing me cole
hardman but you're throwing travis
kelsey and it becomes wow
but just talking about receivers that
may be it all right let's try this the
most up-and-coming receiver duo in the
nfl is who
up and coming
i'm gonna go with one you've heard me
talk about before oh i don't know here
you know what i'm gonna go with
pittsburgh and deontay johnson and chase
claypool you know
that's it's a tough one it to me it's
between them or terry mclaurin and
curtis samuel and that combination there
what about what about jamar chase and t
higgins well that is definitely an
up-and-comer yes i mean that that has a
chance to be special you got a guy
that's fast as hell and can do
everything and then you got this big
giant and t higgins who can just beat
you with pure size and everything like
that uh with but i think the one i'm
going to go with i'm going to go with
deontay johnson and chase claypole the
only reason i'm hesitating on that is
because they have a third in juju where
i get worried he might steal some of
their stats or things like that but man
i'm a big fan of deonte johnson and what
he can do
as far as route running can beat you
deep and do stuff like that and then you
know what i think of chase claypool i
mean i think he's a absolute bonafide
superstar uh so i guess i'll go with
those two there it's a close one though
there was just something last year with
with chase claypool whether it was ben
rothersberger couldn't get the ball down
the field or they didn't want to give
him too much too soon in his career i
don't know but if they fully embrace
chase claypole he's got the potential to
be a superstar mine was and will be who
did i say jamar chase and t higgins how
about this one most underrated receiving
duo in the nfl let me go first on this
one because this one jumped off the page
at me and i think this is the right
answer and i bet you're going to agree
with me keenan allen and mike williams
it's a really good one
it is i guess i have them written down
as one of the great duos here for sure
and they are underrated because keenan
allen is all the catches he might not be
as sexy with the highlight type plays
but he's an amazing receiver and mike
williams a little the same way i don't
know why he gets lost in the shelf i
know he's banged up a little bit last
year too and had some injuries but i i'm
with you i think they are one of the
more underrated ones i think the one i'm
going to go is the most underrated and
doesn't to me is towards the top of
football in the bet i left them out of
the conversation here because i didn't
want you to steal them later is is the
dj moore and robbie anderson won
in carolina that's another one that i
look at to go i mean those are both
thousand yard receivers and
like highlight making type talents to
where i look at them is probably the
most underrated or at least talked about
i mean to the point where curtis samuel
lives in free agency and it's just good
it's just like oh okay we still got we
still got more than robbie and right
the batman in most need of a robin is
who
when i think of the wide receiver just
you know when we keep it strictly to
wide receivers
i
i don't i want to say tyree kill
i i don't i don't know i mean
the devante adams and deandre hopkins
come to my mind certainly
but i feel like if tyree kill
had like a sami watkins where we thought
he was supposed to be sammy watkins and
healthy and just hitting on all
cylinders like i i just i wonder how
much more dangerous he could be you know
i mean nicole hardman's been good but
not quite as good as i at least would
have expected and you could tell not as
good as they expect because they take
them out of the lineup times and
demarcus robinson's in there and
everything like that but if they had
another like unreal
number two receiver next to tyree kill
right now
i i guess i just go wow that would be
scary i know they got good but i don't
know if it's a robin good to classify it
that way
i know they got some faith in byron
pringle and i don't know if that's a
result of me cole hardman not being what
they thought so pringle looks good in
comparison but they really like byron
pringle and we'll see what he can
develop into this year you mentioned
devontae adams i mean i i look at that
question of which batman needs a robin
if i'm batman at the receiver position i
want another batman
i want julio jones if i'm aj brown i
want reggie wayne if i'm marvin harris i
want
torey holt if i'm isaac bruce because
that's the best way to pump up your own
game not to have a guy who's who's your
number two because that guy's gonna get
all the favorable match-ups i want pick
your poison and the only way you do that
is with a couple of batman i i i think
fat men maybe batman
badminton
plurals batman uh but yeah i i mean i'm
here i think the common thought and i i
heard
like
receivers say this back when i played
every now that you think oh if we have
two number ones then i won't get the
ball as much and you go no no no there's
plenty of balls to go around wes welker
caught 120 passes and randy moss still
caught 70 or 80 or like you're talking
about reggie and and marvin there was
there's plenty to go around and like you
said i think that's the key is when you
have another batman to your batman then
you don't get the you might get favored
in certain situations or oh it's third
and four they like to work this receiver
so maybe we'll double him here but
you're right you have a better chance of
seeing more favorable coverages that way
when there's a true stud on the other
side of you
yeah even if you get fewer balls it's a
lot easier everything it's going to be
bigger places
yes you're going to get open right
you're not gonna you're not gonna have
the same hassle when you've got multiple
guys trying to keep you from doing what
it is you wanna do the most balanced
offensive quartet quarterback running
back two receivers in the nfl currently
are who chris
it's
it's it's it's either i i think i know
we haven't seen tennessee but it's hard
for me to not say them your minnesota
vikings i think are definitely i mean
you know it's a lot like the tennessee
combination it's like whoa it's two
number one receivers and maybe the
second best running back in football you
know with a good quarterback
um
i think i'm i'm gonna
the seattle one lacks the running back
to me to be like in quite in that class
am i i don't think i'm missing i mean
dallas we haven't mentioned you know
them with cd lamb and amari cooper um
i i still think i'm gonna go julio and a
uh aj brown here with with ryan
tannehill and derek henry
i and you know i'm surprised you haven't
started blowing the horn but
kirk cousins dalvin cook justin
adam thielen i know offensive line needs
to hold its own irv smith needs to take
advantage of the openings now that he's
the very tight end defense needs to it's
good a little better than it was last
year but but that foursome i don't
well
i i mean we've seen it that's where you
got you have the advantage with your
pick there you're right we haven't seen
julio and everything like that but i i
either way i look at it as special and
special that that's for sure you know
there's a lot of ones that are real
close to it right i mean you know hey
when you talk about mike evans chris
goblin brady and
it's just the running back doesn't quite
match maybe some of the other ones we're
talking about here the browns have the
potential to be obj landry baker nick
chubb i mean wow that could be really
special too there's some good ones out
there cooper cup robert woods you know
uh cam akers not not bad there with
matthew stafford so there's there's
certainly you know some offenses and
some talent to go around in this
discussion that's for sure yeah you know
we mentioned the 1la team as an
underrated duo in keenan island and mike
williams cooper cup and robert woods
when you throw in 2-2 out well and
deshawn jackson
and matthew stafford
that could be i know very compelling and
if only they had listened to jaylen
ramsey and gotten julio jones i still i
still i'm still surprised that
that players
who are among those responsible for huge
cap numbers don't understand
that there's only so many that a team
can have and uh hopefully les snead or
sean mcveigh have that conversation with
jalen ramsey just like yeah we'd like to
have him too but you can't you can't get
every great player who happens to be
available
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports